hagamos un ejemplo sobre cómo encontrar
la magnitud de un vector con solo un
poco de información sobre el se me
ocurre que uno de los casos más simples
será cuando nos dicen las componentes de
un vector por ejemplo si nos dicen que
el vector
tiene como componentes no sé se me
ocurre 5 y como componente en game menos
3 - 3 entonces cuál va a ser la magnitud
de este vector
cuál va a ser la magnitud de este vector
y bueno simplemente será y recuerda que
todo esto sale de la fórmula de la
distancia que viene del teorema de
pitágoras esta magnitud va a ser igual a
la escuadra adam a la raíz cuadrada de
la componente x elevada al cuadrado
así que si ésta es la componente x me va
a quedar 5 elevado al cuadrado más la
componente quien la componente ya está
elevada al cuadrado más menos 3 esto
elevado al cuadrado y esto a que va a
ser igual bueno pues esto va a ser igual
a la raíz cuadrada de 5 al cuadrado lo
cual es 25 25 más menos 3 elevado al
cuadrado lo cual es no
ok y si ahora sumamos estos dos que me
va a dar bueno pues esto va a ser igual
a la raíz cuadrada de 25 más 9 lo cual
es 34 la raíz cuadrada de 34 ahora bien
si tú quieres ver este mismo problema de
una manera gráfica va a ser muy sencillo
solo viendo las componentes que tenemos
aquí es más de esta misma forma
vamos a ver de una manera gráfica el
teorema de pitágoras así que para esto
vamos a dibujar nuestros ejes por aquí
voy a dibujar a mi game este va a ser mi
game y bueno por aquí por aquí me voy a
tomar a mi eje x porque mis componentes
son 5 menos 3 así que vamos a poner los
nombres este de aquí va a ser mi eje y
este otro de aquí va a ser mi eje
es y ahora sí si vemos nuestro
componente x va a ser 5 por lo tanto voy
a poner que el 1 2 3 4 y 5 aquí tengo el
valor de 5 en x y mi componente lleva a
ser de menos 3 así que vamos a bajar 3 1
2 3
este es el valor de menos 3 y con esto
podemos dibujar al vector porque nuestro
vector va a tener como punto inicial el
origen y después lo vamos a llevar 5
unidades a la derecha en x y 3 unidades
hacia abajo en quien hasta llegar a este
punto final el cual va a ser el punto 5
coma menos 3 y bueno ya que tengo este
punto entonces va a ser muy fácil trazar
al vector empezamos aquí y llegamos
hasta acá este base en mi vector a ojo
recuerda que puedes moverlo de un lado a
otro y lo puedes cambiar de sitio
mientras no cambia su magnitud
su dirección así que ya está este va a
ser nuestro vector y si tú quieres
averiguar su magnitud observa que va a
ser solamente la longitud de esta línea
y con ello podemos dibujar un triángulo
rectángulo por aquí donde tú cambio el
iev va a ser desde aquí hasta acá lo
cual nos da el valor de menos 3 este
menos 3 que tenemos aquí y tu cambio en
x va a ser desde este punto hasta acá lo
cual nos va a dar el valor de 5 y ahora
observamos que aquí tenemos este
triángulo rectángulo entonces se va a
cumplir que si tomamos uno de los lados
y lo elevamos al cuadrado en este caso
va a ser 5 elevado al cuadrado y nos
tomamos el otro de los lados y cuidado
si éste va a ser uno de los lados de
nuestro triángulo nos tenemos que tomar
el valor absoluto de menos 3 lo cual nos
va a dar 3 entonces 5 al cuadrado más 3
al cuadrado va a ser lo mismo que la
hipotenusa elevada al cuadrado lo cual
viene del teorema de pitágoras